saw it making an amazing scene at the
press conferences its rise of the Tomb
Raider and brian horton the game
director is here to talk about it with
me Brian how's it going it's pretty
exciting III yeah I mean we were just
talking about this I think it's probably
one of the best e3's we've seen in a
decade it's wonderful and rise of the
Tomb Raider is a big part of that for me
personally at least tomb raider is one
of the rare games that i really felt a
compulsion to 100% to just explore i got
so lost in that world and i absolutely
loved it that's great we were really
proud of everything we were able to do
on the last game but rise of the Tomb
Raider we believe is really stepping
things up in a major way and I'd love to
talk to you guys about that right so
you're stepping what is stepping up mean
because you guys kind of laid yourself a
foundation for a new Lara Croft kind of
experience kind of vibe but you know
stepping up often means sort of changing
the flow of the entire game I mean
really sequel really for us it's just we
want to make Lara Croft the most
believable human character in video
games and she's central to that but
above and beyond that this is her first
great tomb writing expedition on the
last game she was about survival and
that's still part of our tone but now
she's going out there and seeking out
these lost secrets in the dark darkest
farthest corners of the world and it's
it's it's been a great evolution in her
character and it's sort of you know now
she's survived her ordeal on the island
she's probably a little bit more I don't
know prepared for things to go haywire
which is not to say that when things go
haywire she's not gonna be a little
overwhelmed yeah we definitely need to
have that feeling of she goes into this
environment with their climbing gear two
axes ready to go this avalanche hits her
and then she has to start from zero but
she has these survival skills built in
from our experience and she feels at
home here this is part of her destiny
and these challenges and being a tomb
raider is really what she's meant to be
so part of the survival in Tomb Raider
was about that exploration was about
sort of finding things in the
environment that would allow you to
tweak your gear a little bit that it
would allow you to sort of stay strong
and grow your your abilities I you know
in sort of this more targeted tomb
exploration focus you guys have is that
still part of the game it's a huge part
of the game
we've taken idea of upgrades and because
we want her character to evolve not only
story wise but also through gameplay so
now the upgrades were once it was maybe
like a simple XP upgrade we now have the
deer that you kill have hide resource
and antlers and you can collect other
things like wood in the world you can
create these crafting recipes out of 16
unique ingredients to upgrade your
weapons and your ammunition we have
really cool new mo which is called the
poison arrow you can take out multiple
guys with one shot I mean it's just it's
really nice to see us flushing out these
with one shot how does that even work
one arrow one person that's an I'm
that's my this cloud of poison gas oh
wow gobble yeah they are we alright I
like it alright so we you know during
this sort of scene from the press
conference we do this exploration and we
get a look at the fact that Laura is a
company she's not on her own and yo she
had us other survivors she would sort of
connect with in Tomb Raider but this
feels like this guy's along for the ride
in a bigger way Jonah it was actually in
the last game yeah so he's one of our
one of the characters who brought over
and he's a loyal companion to Laura but
as you see in this footage from the
gameplay they do get separated by the
Avalanche so in the classic term writing
tradition it's a solo sport it's a solo
sport now let's talk about the classic
tomb raiding condition because laura is
now you know she's going to this one
area we sort of get a glimpse of the the
castle maybe and on the distance he's
aiming towards is this does the whole
game revolve around this sort of one
expedition or are there multiple the
chill embarked on or will it take her to
other locations well we we have teased
out one environment that's different
than Siberia I won't go into a lot of
detail about that but it will have
different climates even this one
location but ultimately what we're
trying to do here is create this great
drama this great expedition that is is
fueled with mystery and intrigue in
history and the the tombs are back in
Tomb Raider that's really what I got to
say I mean if you're a tomb raider fan
and you wanted two min a more
significant way they're bigger they're
more complex and the rewards that you
get from them are seriously substantial
and central to the plot of Tomb Raider
the tubes are not just about you know
they're they're sort of a mix of all
that tomb raider has off its mix of
exploring and scouting the land its a
mix of figuring out environmental
puzzles and there's also combat
absolutely that it's that that the three
pillars of our game all exists in a tomb
and the way we've expanded on it instead
of making 11 puzzle for one tomb it's
broken up on what we call nested puzzles
which is kind of like the multi lock and
key event classic tomb raider but we're
using our physics-based puzzle system to
have multiple puzzles that will help get
you through to the final destination so
it's a really robust and you know I
really think the tomb raider fan is
going to be excited about what we have
to offer i'm intrigued to see sort of
where you guys land on the puzzle
difficulty right because it's always a
challenge you have to make the puzzle
intriguing enough that the player
doesn't just feel like oh I'll just like
go around in the circle and find all the
things to solve the puzzle you think
there has to be a little bit of uh you
know you got to figure this out involved
and there were a few moments like that
in Tomb Raider you guys are up in the
ante this time around yeah well we want
to make sure because we're going with a
nested puzzle formula it's not that the
puzzle is so complex that you can't
figure it out it just has multi stages
that makes your brain work in different
ways but not so complex to the point
where you're going to be stuck in there
for an hour trying to figure out where
to go we want to make sure that the
action fan that loved the last tomb
raider is going to be satisfied and then
the classic tomb raider fan is going to
get a little bit more robust expression
of puzzle solving now I you know before
we wrap up here I've got a question
about sort of Laura herself right she
said she's a more seasoned adventurer
now she's stared death in the face and
you know in a situation like this
actually died in like some pretty brutal
ways yeah which you know was one of the
more really interesting design choices I
thought you guys made with the last game
because it made me feel a little like I
didn't like seeing them every time
that's the whole idea drama has to have
consequence you can't set up a situation
like this Avalanche and not you know if
you fail at it you you had there has to
be a death there has to be a consequence
now the brutality of those things we
just we introduced the Siberian grizzly
now you can imagine what happens if you
mess up no in that situation I would
tell my imagination to think about a
Siberian grizzly my leg Laura because it
will it will is right now Brian ah but I
mean Laura's so
that physicality that connection the
player has with with Laura with that
character is so important to how the
game feels how the game plays did you
guys sort of take any make any changes
in terms of the design of Laura's
animations and her character to reflect
her sort of experiences absolutely we
brandon fernandez our animation director
believes he wants to create characters
we call the living laura moments
contextual like when she's going through
the deep snow you'll see her exertion is
she's climbing up the mountain we
actually carve out tracks in the snow
physical deformation of the snow so
Laura's connection to her environment is
essential and we do that through
hundreds and hundreds of custom
animations that are all playable so that
that idea that bar it feels connected to
our world is central to that experience
fantastic and yeah it certainly is
looking beautiful I mean technical
performance and like artistry is
something you guys set a pretty high
standard for in Tomb Raider and it's
something you're leaning into this time
around as well yeah we're you know our
our team is second to none the best
artists best tech best animation in the
industry and these guys are pad you know
there are other artists at Tech and
animators out here i'm biased maybe a
little bit but I you know seriously here
you Brian the team at Crystal Oh a
little bit of tidbit to it's not just
Crystal Dynamics our partners at aedas
Montreal Arco developing this game with
us no kiddin and we couldn't be more
excited to have that additional talent
and blood helping us make this what we
believe is the best tomb raider game
we've ever made the best tomb raider
game you guys have ever made big words
big ambitions but so far to rise of the
Tomb Raider looking really good I let's
talk a little bit about when it's coming
out and sort of how you guys are
releasing it because that was something
that after last year's e3 folks required
a little bit of clarification on sure so
we've had a fantastic partnership with
Microsoft they've been extremely
supportive you can look at our booth we
have a prestige place within their
within their organization it's a little
cave and every they love it they really
have been very big supports and they
believed in our vision from the start so
it's been a really great partnership for
us we are coming out this November 10th
this year 2015 on xbox one and xbox 360
and we couldn't be more happy with the
way things are going so far well Brian
thank you so much for coming on
attacking rise of the Tomb Raider
looking great here at
be 2015 thanks a lot all right folks
coming up next we've got more game demos
here on the live stage for honor it says
they got a schedule / that's really
handy for honored see it after ubisoft
press conference with the swords axes in
the we're going to be talking about it
seeing it in action in just a moment
you